head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts we're
going to start with this story from
Ashley stclair because you know I'll be
completely honest I think this is we
have we have a great opportunity to talk
about uh much much larger issues as
we're we're ending out the year uh
tomorrow we'll have James O'Keefe and it
will be our last show of the year so
we're really excited but uh this is
still a very interesting story coming
from Ashley Sinclair which can kick off
an immigration discussion Ashley
Sinclair tweets I am in possession of
legitimate major airline boarding passes
for migrants that quite literally have
the name printed as no name given
incredibly incredibly difficult to post
these without putting the Insiders at
risk working on it this will continue to
unfold over the coming weeks but I
confirm these are legitimate boarding
passes I am at a loss for words for what
I am verifying thank you to everybody
reaching out Ashley stclair also tweets
receiving all of these tips was able to
call many sources directly here on X a
pilot who wanted to remain anous
anonymous was able to create a burner
account join our space and use the
built-in voice change feature to stay
safe she then celebrates act the best
platform so far but the big news that
we've been seeing over the uh past
couple of days is record-breaking
illegal immigration flowing into Eagle
Pass we're seeing now over 10,000 per
day they're estimating around 270 or so
thousand individuals coming in just this
month and it's resulting in even
Democrats in cities like Chicago where
we're getting uh a lot of anger let me
see if I have this one uh not that one
where where's the the story yet do we
have the uh well we have this one from
the Daily Mail Furious Chicago resident
rips into mayor Brandon Johnson for
throwing open the door to thousands of
migrants and letting down black
communities I think this is obviously a
major issue and some of the latest polls
on Donald Trump show that he is uh uh
Rising significantly especially on among
young people people and it's because the
economy and immigration are huge issues
for people but uh let's just we can just
kick off the conversation with you
maryan and I'm curious what your
thoughts are on all of this I think that
in this as in so many areas we have to
treat root causes we have to ask we have
to ask why are people working going
through sometimes the most hideous
Journeys like through the Daran Gap the
Daran Gap in Mexico is one of the most
inhospitable areas in the world so what
would make someone walk across the
daring Gap with two small children well
obviously desperation so what what is
the despair there are two main
categories one has to do with economic
destabilization in these countries uh
which has caused all this economic
desperation and the other is the
horrible violence that is perpetrated by
the drug cartels now I think that we
need to look in the mirror because if we
look at all of this economic despair a
lot of it was contributed to mly by US
foreign policy over over the last few
decades one of the things that we have
to do for instance we need to end the
sanctions on Cuba we have to end the
sanctions on Venezuela I think a lot of
people have no idea what violence this
does to the lives of ordinary people we
say to ourselves well we're going to
have a sanction on this country and it's
a sanction against the bad guys who are
the leaders and then the story went that
uh the ordinary citizen in that country
would realize that that this is what was
causing it and they'd rise up against
the leader well it doesn't work that way
first of all the leader has
cryptocurrency the leader has bank
accounts in Switzerland the leader has
castles in mon Carlo we saw this with
the sanctions on the Russian oligarchs
at the beginning of the Ukraine war
they're like whatever right so how
ironic that in countries like Cuba and
Venezuela our sanctions are leading to a
lot of the despair that is then making
people come here we give something like
200 million in general in humanitarian
Aid to um Latin American countries I
think if we really look honestly at what
we have done to many of these countries
over the last few decades we would see a
lot more uh of a reason and a
justification for us seeking to
stabilize helping stabilize some of
these economies I also think that we
should end America's War on Drugs
because our War on Drugs actually
contributes it it helps the drug cartels
because it creates all that black market
so I think that we can talk all day long
I was in Eagle Path weeks ago I saw the
concertina wire I saw the buoys that a
federal judge has now told Greg Abbott
that he cannot use I saw where 1500
people drowned in the um Rio Grand River
um and I heard officials down in in
Eagle paath say to me we feel oppressed
by the state government and we feel
neglected by the federal government
because those people who are down there
know how to handle this they know how to
do the processing they know what is
needed and they're not listen to too so
this is interesting we have uh this
story I want to I just want to pull this
up this is from ABC appeals court orders
Texas to remove floating buoys from Rio
Grand that was earlier in uh uh the
month but we also do have this story
from the post-millennial federal judge
forbids Biden Administration from
removing Texas's border barriers so I
think they the the the buoys over the
water I think had to come out because of
international waterways restrictions but
we started to see with the uh the razor
wire uh federal agents were lifting it
up and allowing people to enter and now
I believe that's being barred and Texas
has just passed a state law Banning
illegal entry into the state but the
state Greg Abbott is overriding federal
jurisdiction he does not have once again
this is why they're saying oppressed by
the state government um and neglected by
the US government it Greg Abbott is
taking on Authority that Governors do
not have these are to be these are laws
that are to be passed by congress not by
state Governors well what what happens
when you have 10,000 people per day
entering your state in your city once
again there's nothing you can do on the
level of symptom that's going to
fundamentally fix this this is why we
must address the underlying causes we
can talk about whether or not people are
detained we can talk about whether or
not people are deported but until we
actually address the root cause of the
problem this is going to remain with us
I agree but we can't ignore 10,000
people per day I mean if uh if we use if
you you say symptom I'd imagine someone
gets shot we do need to stop shootings
but you still have to tend to the wound
and also the people that are coming over
they're they're not really predominantly
from South America they're coming from
all over the world so I understand your
point about addressing the the problems
in in you know in South America or
addressing the some of the things like
sanctions and stuff I understand that
but doesn't it like doesn't that not you
know cover the problem if most of the
people are coming from other places like
you know Africa and Asia I think we also
though need to look at the overall
picture of immigration in this country
because that we can have an argument at
numbers and it's a legitimate argument
but I think we also need to stand back
and look at the overall picture which is
statistically an immigrant to this
country from anywhere if they are given
for one year the help that is necessary
to integrate Etc within a year they are
self-sufficient and if you look at the
big picture of immigration in the United
States The Immigrant population is a
contributor to the US economy and not a
suck on the US economy you know 150
years ago it was don't let in the Jews
don't let in the Polish don't let in the
Irish and there's a lot of that same
kind of racism that is going on today so
we have to ask ourselves it's one thing
to have a conversation about the numbers
and the overwhelm but it has to me uh uh
now leaned over into a a mean-spirited
attitude towards immigrants which is not
in keeping
uh with the better angels of our nature
where did your great grandparents come
from I mean all four of my grandparents
came here seeking to escape oppression
what about yours neither of you none of
you are descended from from enslaved
people or from indigenous people are you
I'm part
Korean not by the United States they
were not enslaved by the United States
but my family was uh persecuted when
during during World War II with Japanese
internment because they didn't care for
the difference between different types
of Asian people so my family was forced
to flee and hide and um my uh my mom
side of the family which was mixed race
had to pretend like they weren't
actually related because it was illegal
at the time because of misation laws and
so the stories I grew up hearing was uh
my family fled 12 different states once
people found out that it was a a mixed
race family you know pre 1967 and would
be Spit On by people for being what they
would call Japs despite the fact that I
am part Japanese but mostly Korean so uh
that is a component and not to say that
we're descendant from American slave or
anything like that but my point is they
so your family
found they found safety and Asylum and a
better life in the United States right
oh yeah absolutely so isn't there a
moral responsibility that those of us
who are descended from people like your
parents like my grandparents who found
that we don't have a moral
responsibility to make sure that others
experience that blessing as well because
there's a whole lot of people in the
world world like that if we have a moral
responsibility to some wouldn't that say
mean we have a moral responsibility to
the to the world and then that's a moral
responsibility to everybody on Earth no
not everybody's trying to come here
would even want to come here I imagine
there's a lot of people that want to
that I I I think the answer is yes legal
immigration I'm sorry oh sorry I was
going to I was going to agree I believe
the answer is yes however it has to be
legal yeah right we we right now what
you know with with I think your view on
we must treat the symptoms there's a lot
of symptoms and I can respect absolutely
I question when we give money to these
South American and Central American
countries and their oligarchs and their
autocrats steal the money and it doesn't
help the people at all and exacerbates
violence the drug or all that absolutely
I want to treat that but then there is
another issue the American citizens of
Eagle Pass are suffering and I don't
believe it would be appropriate to just
say we will provide no reprieve for you
in the immediate because we're dealing
with larger issues
internationally said I was just in Eagle
Pass go down to past because I think you
might be surprised by the stories that
you hear from the people there you know
I grew up in Texas I grew up in Houston
people have been walking back and forth
Mexico and Texas literally for centuries
yeah literally for centuries and the
people in the eagle P that I spoke to
absolutely know how these processing
centers could work how the medical could
work it it could be set up very
differently than it is and the people in
Eagle Pass are the ones who would know
what to do but what about for instance
the people in Chicago the black
community specifically that has been an
upro over the the past several months
you said that plane came from Phoenix so
my question was which Governor like we
know for instance remember when Greg
Abbott sent all those um immigrants on a
bus to Massachusetts is Massachusetts a
sanctuary State pardon is that is
Massachusetts a sanctuary it was a it
was a to something and now when you read
the follow-up stories they're all doing
well well they yeah but they they were
deported out of net pardon they were
removed from Nantucket the the local
residents revolted and then put them all
in buses and sent them out yeah they
they were there for like a week and then
they were like get beat it get out of
here they were complaining they were
they were having having uh meetings Town
meetings and stuff that we don't have a
place to put the put all the people we
don't you know we're we're a a vacation
town and blah blah blah they could have
put him in Massachusetts is a sanctuary
is is a deao sanctuary State according
to wgbh.org so the argument I suppose
from the likes of Texas is if the
federal government is going to remove
border barriers allow the these people
to enter under their Federal
jurisdiction why not send these people
to states that welcome them no I
understand but then you end up with
Chicago residents and so Chicago it's
it's devastating because that's I'm from
I bring that only because I'm from there
I know this is affecting a bunch of
other cities my friends are saying the
police departments are done they're shut
down basically because they were overrun
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net Ed membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time